Guten Morgen Linus. Guten.
Guten Morgen, Andre.
Herzlich willkommen zu Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Ist ja schon fast wie bei den Fan-Boys hier.
Bist hier Gast und sagst noch nicht mal guten Morgen zu Tim oder was?
Guten Morgen Tim.
Nee, ja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt hast du den Fanboy, den, den Visis Circle hast du jetzt irgendwie an die Wand gemalt, jetzt wird's hier.
Äh gut, dann machen wir's halt halt mal anders. Äh ihr werdet es schon mitbekommen haben. Wir haben André wieder bei uns. Hallo. Hallo Andre. Moin.
Und ich will mich beschweren. Ich will mich beschweren, weil sich keiner beschwert hat, äh dass wir letztes Mal ein Intro hatten.
Ja, nichts. Nichts. Nur Crickets und.
Nickers. Wussten wahrscheinlich alle, was das für eine Melodie ist.
Tja, keine Ahnung. Könnt ihr ja mal raten. Könnt ja mal raten.
Die wussten das wahrscheinlich.
Normal gemacht,
Wir wollen überhaupt mehr Feedback haben hier. Nicht, nicht, nicht, dass es ein Mangel daran gäbe, aber wir können erstens sowieso nicht äh äh genug kriegen von allem.
Und äh ja, haben wir auch sonst nichts zu tun. Stimmt's?
Nee, denn äh die Themen sind ja sowieso immer die gleichen, ne. Hier unsere Themenwolke anschaut und so weiter.
Ja, die Themenwolke ähm müssen wir bald mal irgendwie ein paar Tex Newton, aber äh ein Thema, was wir jetzt äh neu wieder haben, ist SPD und Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Spannende, das Spannende zu dem Thema ist, es.
Oh, super. Ich gucke gerade mal, ob ich noch Wunderkerzen habe.
Spannend zu dem Thema ist, es gibt nix Neues.
Doch man hat drüber geredet.
Wo denn? Eigentlich, die haben sich getroffen irgendwo.
In Vibra, im Willi Willy-Brandt-Haus. Da habe ich jetzt mal so genannt.
Vibra, was ist das denn? Ach so. Oh, heißt das so? Ach so. Verstehe. Okay und, und, und, und da wurde dann darüber gesprochen, dass man das ja an sich äh ganz toll findet oder wie?
Na ja, da kamen so ähm,
kamen einige illustre Personen zu Wort, unter anderem Sigmar Gabriel und äh der Jörg Zirke, unser BKA äh Chef
ähm und ähm haben dann natürlich erzählt, wie fürchterlich das alles ist und weil wir keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben, hatten wir die NSU-Morde so ungefähr und,
ganz fürchterlich und ähm.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätte, hätte das verhindert oder was?
Ja, also ist genau dieser typische dieses typische Gewicht da gewäscht. Da wollen wir vielleicht auch gar nicht das alles irgendwie nochmal wiederholen, dass er wirklich inzwischen äh olle Kamelle äh die EU-Richtlinie muss umgesetzt werden, sonst drohen uns Strafzahlungen und wat nicht alles,
ähm.
Vorgeschichte hatten wir ja Lokbuch Netzpolitik berichtete war dieser Parteitagsbeschluss am Dezember zweitausendelf, vierter bis sechster Dezember war glaube ich dieser Parteitag, wo sie sich dann zu ihrer,
deutlichen Einschränkungen der Vorratsspeicherung. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit menschlichem Antlitz.
Ja, ich habe den, ich habe den hier nochmal rausgesucht.
Datenschutz und Grundrechte stärken, Datenspeicherung begrenzen, ja? Also Vollformat, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber nicht hier sechs Monate, sondern ich glaube, sie wollten dann wie weniger?
Ähm.
Und äh so wird dann auch jetzt grade bei der SPD darüber berichtet, die Verhältnismäßigkeit waren. Ja und äh da erzählen sie dann also wie die SPD ähm stolz die Verhältnismäßigkeit wahrt.
Und äh weiterhin für die für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist. Ähm immerhin lobende Erwähnung findet die das Mitgliederbegehren, Sozis gegen VDS,
welches wir damals auch schon erwähnt hatten. Ja. Dieses Mitgliederbegehren ist also dann auch glaube ich der,
Man könnte sagen, jedem Parteimitglied die Partei, die es verdient hat oder oder wie würde man das oder jeder Partei, die Mitglieder, die sie verdient hat, ähm dieses Mitgliederbegehren gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung bräuchte,
ungefähr, ich glaube achtundvierzigtausendfünfhundert Unterschriften,
und hat bis jetzt eintausendsiebenhundertsiebenundachtzig. Das ist natürlich relativ mager und es gibt nur noch achtundzwanzig Tage Zeit für die SPD,
um da irgendwie mehrere, also mehr als fünfundvierzigtausend Unterschriften noch zu sammeln auf dieser Seite, ähm das wird.
Ist bis zum vierundzwanzigsten Oktober muss das geschehen, kann man auch per Post machen, aber es sieht im Moment nicht danach aus, als würde das den äh SPD Parteimitgliedern noch.
Kann das per Post machen. Man hätte ja den Eindruck, das muss per Post funktionieren. Dann musst du ein Formular runterladen, das musst du dann.
Entschuldigung, ich habe jetzt gedacht, da ist eine Internetseite und dann habe ich auch gedacht.
Per Post. Hier steht ein kleines FAQ. Leider dürfen wir Unterstützung nur unterschrieben per Post annehmen. Das sieht so an die Richtlinie vom SPD Bundesvorstand zur Mitgliederbegehren vor,
Telefax oder elektronische übermittelte Unterschriften sind ungültig.
Telefax.
Frage ich mich ja, warum der SPD Bundesvorstand wohl diese Regelungen für seine Mitgliederbegehren implementiert hat, ja.
Na, damit das auch alles äh äh seine seine Ordnung hat, ne.
Seine Ordnung hat. Seine Ordnung. Mhm.
Dennis Muhat macht das. Alles klar.
Macht das, ja?
Ja, der macht auch einen Podcast im Übrigen.
Der macht auch ein Podcast und der macht auch ganz viel mit Internet und äh äh wie heißt D vierundsechzig und so. Hat noch Hoffnung, hat auf jeden Fall, sollte sich jetzt mal, wenn da noch was kommt, auf jeden Fall schon mal einen größeren Briefkasten kaufen.
Hm, na gut, aber ich meine, seit wann läuft das Ding dieses Begehren?
Das ist schon Ewigkeiten.
Ewigkeiten. Hier steht noch achtundzwanzig Tage, das kann noch nicht für äh zehn Monate laufen.
Also.
Das geht mindestens einen Monat. Das ist als Reaktion entstanden eben auf dem Parteitagsbeschluss im Dezember äh Sozis gegen VDS gibt's irgendwie seit dreiundzwanzigsten Juli, glaube ich oder so,
zwei, drei Monate, jetzt tausendsiebenhundert äh Unterschriften,
und die Konferenz, die gestern im Brandhaus stattfindet, ist, glaube ich, eine direkte Reaktion auf dieses Mitgliederbegehren.
Wie wir gerade sehen, gibt es das Mitgliederbegehren seit dem vierundzwanzigsten Juli.
Läuft also seit zwei Monaten und noch einen Monat. Also es scheint nicht grade sonderlich einzuschlagen. Das Thema äh wobei ich das nicht einschätzen kann, ob das jetzt sozusagen ein Mangel an Publikationen hat oder einfach nur einen Mangel an Unterstützung.
Wahrscheinlich beides.
Man kann sich diese Konferenz, die da stattgefunden hat, auch im, im in der Nähe angucken, aufm YouTube,
Glaube ich, also es sieht aus wie ein YouTube Link hier. Und äh da kann man sich anschauen, wie äh Ulf
der Richter am Landgericht Berlin ist und auch im Umfeld des digitale Gesellschaft EV und des Chaos Computerclubs sich engagiert,
der sagte dann dem äh dort, dass er als Richter es noch nicht erlebt habe, dass irgendwelche Daten nicht verfügbar seien,
Äh bereits heute seien alle Daten bei den Providern zur Verfügung. Ähm,
Allerdings müssen sich die Ermittlungsbehörden ein bisschen beeilen, damit sie die noch kriegen, bevor die Fristen abgelaufen sind. Und das wäre ja eigentlich genau der Zustand, den man sich eigentlich wünschen würde. Das hat er da gesagt,
Fand ich mal sehr spannend, denen das so sagen zu hören äh in diesem Umfeld, wo auch ein Jörg Zirkel dann eben am gleichen Tisch steht,
der äh ja seit Jahren das Gegenteil behauptet.
Na gut, sollten wir äh Sozialdemokraten hier unter unseren Hörern haben, die vielleicht von diesem Begehren noch nichts gewusst haben und äh auch Gedenken es zu unterstützen, dann findet ihr den Link bei uns in den.
Ja, dann gab's eine sehr schöne, sehr schöne ähm,
sehr schönen Artikel, den ich so gelesen habe,
Und zwar geht es um die um die Piratenpartei, die sowohl die Bundespiratenpartei als auch die Piratenpartei
NRW haben ja jetzt äh ausführlichere äh Veröffentlichung zum Urheberrecht gemacht und vor allem die Piratenpartei NRW hat eine,
quasi ein äh Urheberrechtsgesetz Änderungsentwurf. Das ist ein relativ großes Dokument von äh
zweiundneunzig Seiten, wo dann jeweils die einzelnen Paragraphen, wie sie gestrichen oder verändert werden sollen, äh dabeistehen plus Begründung.
Das ist mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu lang, ähm aber es geht ihnen dabei hauptsächlich darum, äh ja, also eine fairen,
Äh fairen Austausch zwischen Urhebern und Nutzern zu schaffen und äh das muss alles sehr viel besser und,
so werden. Und was wir dazu feststellen ist, dass äh die Kritik aus der Basis laut wird an zwei Personen, zwei Damen aus der Piratenpartei,
die nämlich äh während die Piratenpartei ja immer sehr betont, dass,
man nach alternativen Geschäftsmodellen Ausschau halten sollte und dass die äh dass wir quasi einen näheren Kontakt zwischen Künstler und ähm,
Künstler, Kunde oder Verbraucher haben wollen, also Crowdfunding, Geschäftsmodelle und so, das zwei äh Damen der Piratenpartei jetzt äh Bücher veröffentlichen und zwar mit traditionellen Urheberrechtsmodell des Verlages,
inklusive Durchsetzung der Uhrabtreten der Urheberrechte an den Verlag und Durchsetzung selbiger durch den Verlag. Ist ja eigentlich eine.
Nicht verboten, ne?
Ist nicht verboten, ist nicht verboten. Die Kritik lautet so ungefähr, wenn wir als Partei groß rumposaunen, dass wir nicht über dass wir überholte Geschäftsmodelle nicht äh staatlich schützen wollen,
äh und sagen die Künstler sollen äh sich Alternativ nach Alternativen Einnahmequellen und direkteren äh,
umsehen, dann ist es ein schlechtes Signal, wenn unsere äh unsere meistbeachteten Figuren diese so etwas nicht selbst machen, quasi an die eigene,
Lehre nicht glauben. Ich glaube, die Bild-Zeitung hatte in irgendeinem Zusammenhang geschrieben, die Piraten äh predigen Wein und trinken Wasser.
Sieg.
Und, also, ich meine, Leute sagen und wer sagt das? Äh äh Leute im Internet und die Bild-Zeitung
Ich meine, das ist doch nun wirklich der Schrei nach Symbolpolitik,
da habe ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt gar kein Verständnis für diese ganze Debatte. Ich finde die vollkommen vollkommen bekloppt und absurd.
Weil äh erstmal immer so äh Galionsfiguren da so äh in den Ring zu äh schmeißen und sagen, lebe uns ein gutes Leben vor, äh
bin zu faul äh äh selber was beizutragen. Sei du jetzt hier äh unser Maskottchen und und und mache alles so wie wie wir das für richtig halten und äh entscheide nicht selbst. Das das finde ich einfach vollkommen äh bekloppt und absurd.
Fall von Julia Schramm finde ich sogar noch viel bekloppter und absurder, weil es einfach mal überhaupt einfach äh erstmal
ihr Ding ist und zweitens jeder auch Sachen vorgeworfen werden, die sie die sie nicht gesagt hat.
Ich rede von Marina Weißband.
Ja, du hast von zwei Damen gesprochen, meinem Freund.
Äh ja, aber ja seriös. Seriously, ich meine, es ist äh äh das, dass Marina das äh,
ohne DAM da durchkämpft, finde ich okay. Ich meine, wo ist das Problem? Ich sehe da, ich sehe da überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Ich sehe auch kein Problem, also äh ich erwähne nur, dass die Partei ja im Prinzip hauptsächlich die Position vertritt, dass ein solches Geschäftsmodell als überholt gilt.
Sehe schon eine gewisse Dissonanz zwischen dem Anspruch auf geistiges Eigentum komplett zu scheißen,
und für die Privatkopie in jeglicher Ausprägung zu sein und dann aber nichts dagegen zu haben oder das vorher anzukündigen, dass der Verlag natürlich das PDF vom eigenen Buch äh mit DNCA Take Download ist, entfernen wird,
So funktioniert das System, aber die
Menschen sind keine Privatpersonen, ausschließlich, sondern die haben eine Funktion in einer Partei, die sich eben genau dieses Thema auf die Fahne geschrieben hat,
und das jetzt wegwischen zu wollen, also ich finde die schon, in diesem Kernthema könnte da etwas mehr Stringenz angebracht sein.
Naja, also ich habe nicht gerade so den Eindruck, dass dass die äh Piratenpartei besonders äh konsequent sich,
ganz klar zu definierende Aussagen auf ihre Fahnenschreibzeilen. Das ist im Wesentlichen noch immer eine extreme äh Kakophonie,
besondere in diesem ganzen Mienenfeld der äh des uröcherrechts Dialogs oder wie man das nennen soll. Ich meine, die Initiative, die du jetzt hier am Anfang erwähnt hast, äh wer steht dahinter, Daniel Neumann hat dieses
geschrieben, aber du mit Udo Fetter zusammen.
Also dass dieser NRW-Partei.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe so äh den Eindruck, dass äh äh in der Piratenpartei an sich jetzt überhaupt
erst so der Moment einsetzt, wo man mal anfängt, wirklich darüber nachzudenken, äh was man will. Das mag an einzelnen Stellen schon immer irgendwie stattgefunden haben, aber das letzte Jahr war im Wesentlichen
waren sie einfach im Wesentlichen damit beschäftigt Talkshows zu bestücken und sich über ihren eigenen virtuellen Erfolg zu wundern.
Und äh jetzt sind wir halt da äh an der medialen.
An diesem Punkt des medialen Umkippens angekommen, ja? Also was vorher alles ganz toll war, das ist jetzt irgendwie ganz scheiße, interessanterweise hatten wir das ja schon ein bisschen vorhergesagt, wenn das dich hier vielleicht noch in unsere
Folge äh ja, wo wir da sozusagen äh vielleicht noch noch
zuvor schnell ausgerufen haben, aber im Prinzip ist das genau dieser Effekt. Ja, sie waren,
An dem Maximum das äh äh Umjubelns und, und, und, und das zu Schaustellen der Andersartigkeit in der Öffentlichkeit äh angekommen. Es hielt sich dann noch etwas, aber jetzt,
kehrt halt die politische Realität äh ein und während ihm die Aktiven und vor allem diejenigen, die so immer in den Mittelpunkt geschubst werden
jetzt äh vollkommen überarbeitet äh äh sind und äh äh neurodische Störungen ausbrechen. Äh gibt's dann halt immer noch so diese,
Basis, die dann halt äh von unten da weiter shitstormt und jetzt ordnet sich da überhaupt erstmal die ganze Regel, ne?
Moment, also ähm natürlich ist die Piratenpartei eine eine ausgesprochen amüsante Partei, weil äh sie jeden Tag irgendwelches Popcorn äh durchs Land äh äh transportieren lässt. Ähm.
Ich bin sehr es aber schon so, ich bin ja selber ein Verfechter des äh der Idee, dass man das Urheberrecht auch ähm in großen Teilen genauso wie es hier äh in diesem neuen Entwurf
oder in diesem Gesetzesänderungsentwurf von der Piratenpartei NRW vorgeschlagen wird, verändert.
Und ich bin insbesondere für andere Geschäftsmodelle, die sowas wie einen Verlag obsolet machen. Was macht der Verlag oder was macht ein Label? Sie leihen
Personen im Prinzip Geld ein ein Werk zu produzieren. Ähm also das ist dann dieser Vorschuss im Prinzip. Und ähm,
geben im Prinzip ein ein Kredit, damit der Künstler es sich leisten kann,
dieses Werk äh zu schaffen und dann dieses Werk zu vertreiben, das sind die Aufgaben, die der Verlag übernimmt und hat damit quasi die Kontrolle über den Markt,
Markteinstieg dieses dieses geistigen Produktes, was irgendjemand dort schafft.
Plus Lektorat, ne?
Sektorat, so ein bisschen so allumfassende Dienstleistungen. So und jetzt sagt, äh stellt sich eine Marina Weißband hin, konfrontiert mit dem mit dem Vorwurf oder mit der Kritik, die man ja durchaus darf man ja wohl diese Kritik mal äußern, dass man sagt, wir hätten uns von dir gewünscht,
du das, was äh als, also dass du auch deine Symbolkraft nutzt, ähm das, was wir politisch vertreten, auch mal in der realen Welt zu zeigen.
Was hätte sie denn konkret anders machen sollen?
Würde ich ja jetzt grade, wollte ich ja gerade zu ausholen. Diese Debatte fand ja, stand ja fand ja statt, dass ihr gesagt wurde, wir sagen irgendwie, was weiß ich, wir wollen Crowdfunding Modelle, ja, du hättest auf Kickstarter sagen können, ich bin Marina Weißband und ich bringe euch ein Buch,
und es wird wahrscheinlich tatsächlich irgendwie Inhalt haben,
Und ähm das wäre doch schön, wenn ich euch dieses Buch äh reichen könnte und wenn ich das geschrieben habe, dafür brauche ich so und so viel tausend Euro und wenn das fertig ist, gibt's das als äh DRM freies PDF so und so und für einen Fünfer äh kann man das bei mir bestellen.
Beispielsweise, sie hätte auch äh einen PDF raushauen können oder sonst was. Sie hätte irgendwie ein alternatives Finanzierungsmodell für dieses Buch nutzen können. Hat sich aber dafür entschieden,
genau das nicht zu tun, ist auch absolut ihr gutes Recht, völlig freier Mensch, Marina Weißband,
sie muss sich aber dann natürlich von einigen Personen sagen lassen, dass sie enttäuscht sind,
dass sie nicht ihrem, ihre Symbolmöglichkeit genutzt hat, um mal zu zeigen, dass diese anderen Geschäftsmodelle überhaupt funktionieren. Es gibt sehr wenige chillernde Beispiele dafür, dass.
Funktionieren sie auch nicht. Ich meine, Kickstarter ist zum Beispiel schon mal vollkommen falscher Ansatz.
Okay, dann wäre das falsch gewesen. So, aber sie hätte, sie hätte quasi zeigen können, dass diese, dass diese
das das ist mit diesen Modellen irgendwie funktioniert, ähnlich wie es zum Beispiel oder Radio hat, die riesige Erfolge hatten mit Alben, von denen sie die MP3s zum Beispiel verschenkt haben, ja? Das waren die erfolgreichsten äh Radiat und Ninetys Alben, wo sie die MP3s verschenkt haben und dann so Premiummodelle hatten. Irgendwie sowas
Und jetzt gibt's eben die Kritik, dass gesagt wird, du hättest das machen können und dann sagte, antwortete Marina Weißband sinngemäß äh,
Guck mal auf die Uhr, ich bin irgendwie Studentin hier, ich hab viel zu tun, ich hab gar keine Zeit mich selber zu vermarkten.
Und deswegen habe ich mich an einen Verlag gewendet, der mir die Arbeit abnimmt, damit ich mich auf das Buch schreiben konzentrieren kann. Das ist das, was Verlage immer sagen, was ihre Aufgabe ist und was ihre Dienstleistung für den Künstler ist, wofür sie so viel Geld
dann auch dem Künstler am Ende abzwacken wollen.
Und dann lautet die Antwort und ich denke, das ist eine legitime Kritik, wenn du das sagst, die irgendwie alle Möglichkeiten zur Selbstvermarktung hat.
Mit irgendwie sehr theoretisch zur Verfügung stehen hat, mit sehr vielen ähm mit sehr vielen Followern auf Twitter, sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit durch äh Bildzeitung oder sonst was. Ähm wenn du das schon sagst, dass du es nicht schaffst, dich selber zu vermarkten, obwohl du schon ein,
eine Marke bist.
Gesagt, sie hat die Zeit nicht dafür.
Genau, sie hat die Zeit nicht dafür. Wenn du es nicht schaffst, das dich selber zu vermarkten, dann ähm wie sollen wir dann glaubhaft vertreten, dass,
Wir verlangen, dass Künstler andere Künstler es in Zukunft selber machen. Und das ist einfach mal eine ein gerechtfertigter äh Punkt,
Ich sage nicht, dass deswegen Marina weiß, wann ihr Buch irgendwie anders veröffentlichen soll. Selbstverständlich kann sie machen, was sie will.
Ja, aber trotzdem Symbolpolitik, ja? Ich halte doch, dass es, natürlich, hast du das Wort selber eben.
Politik ist.
Du hast, hast du äh nein nein, du hast genau dieses Wort Symbol eben selber verwendet. Ich habe dir das noch nicht mal in den Mund gelegt und genau das ist halt auch der Punkt, ja, andere Leute erwarten, ich meine,
kann da alles mögliche von ihr erwarten oder man kann das jetzt irgendwie finden, aber da irgendwie auch nur eine nennenswerte politische Diskussion rausstricken zu wollen, halte ich einfach für vollkommen beknackt, weil ich meine Crowdfunding, jetzt drehen wir es auch mal von der anderen Seite auf
du sagst Kickstarter, da sage ich irgendwie, ja Kickstarter kommt aber schon mal gar nicht in Frage, weil das ist einfach ein US-Unternehmen im Jahr, das ist.
Aber das ist doch überhaupt nicht das Thema. Das das Thema ist doch einfach, dass natürlich ist es keine politisch.
Nee, ich glaube, dass, ich glaube, dass du das auch oder dass wer auch immer diese Kritik äußert, ähm da einfach auch den Aufwand, sowas zu betreiben, einfach maßlos unterschätzt.
Das mag ja alles sein. Ich gebe das ja erstmal nur wieder, aber man muss doch wohl zugeben, dass das ein dass man sagen kann, dass die Piratenpartei sich etwas schöneres vorstellen könnte für ihre Urheberrechtsdebatten, die sie in Zukunft noch führen wird.
Piratenpartei könnte einfach mal das tun, was sie jetzt hier im Ansatz auch schon gemacht haben, nämlich einfach konkrete Vorschläge machen. Anstatt irgendwie permanent sich damit zu beschäftigen
eigenen Mitglieder auf auf die Klobrille zu setzen und ihn beim Kacken zuzuschauen. Ich finde das wirklich
absurd, weil das nichts kotzt mich so sehr an in diesem politischen Prozess,
wie dieses permanente Rumgepuppe irgendwie auf einzelnen Personen und solchen Symbolmaßnahmen. Ja, ich meine,
Es ist nicht klar, was die Piratenpartei für eine Position hat zur Urheberrechtsreform. Das ist.
Doch alles überhaupt nicht gesagt. Also ich ich weiß gar nicht, ich muss jetzt hier mir einen Blog hinlegen und eine Liste der der Unterstellung äh machen, die die du, die du mir zumindest äh oder.
Mach gar keine Unterstellung, ich sag's nur, man man könne ja erwarten, dass, das heißt, dass es da irgendwie eine klare, erklärbare Linie gibt. Ich sehe diese klar erkennbare Linie bei den Piraten aber nicht. Punkt,
ja? Und ich meine im CCC werden genauso auch Bücher äh über Verlage äh nach demselben Modell auch geschrieben und äh von anderen Vertretern auch äh.
Hat aber auch kein Parteiprogramm.
Ja gut, wissen sie mal, bei Parteien darf man immer draufhauen, äh nicht. Ich finde das einfach absurd. Lass uns über was anderes reden.
Nee, der andere muss noch was sagen. Nee, ich will, dass der andere noch.
Interessanter finde ich jetzt zu sehen, was steht drin in diesen Vorschlägen? Das finde ich interessant, ja? Was sind wirklich die Vorschläge, in welche Richtung soll das gehen.
Da wollte ich ja eigentlich drauf aus, äh bevor du bevor du hier den.
Ja. Naja. Na du bist doch der die Nebelkerzen schmeißt, man.
Ich bitte dich.
Ich finde das Nebelkerzen-Diskussion.
Du bist der, du bist der Mister Crowdfunding. Du bist du bist du musst jetzt herhalten anstelle von Marina Weißwand als jemand, der äh Crowdfunding Möglichkeiten erfolgreich nutzt.
Arbeit auf dich abgewälzt, so sieht's aus.
Ja, weil man kann ja auch nie nicht jemand dazu zwingen. Ich weiß, das ist das ist halt auch äh.
Man will irgendjemanden zwingen, aber man wird doch.
Da wollen Leute sie zwingen und das finde ich halt scheiße.
Marina Weißband darf nicht mehr kritisiert werden.
Darf durchaus kritisiert werden, aber bei der Bitte wirklich für für Dinge, die wirklich politisch sind und nicht äh solche Privatenmaßnahmen sind. Also das das finde ich einfach völlig daneben,
Ehrlich und das finde ich auch im Fall von Julia Schramm
völlig daneben. Sollen jedoch ihre Bücher schreiben, sollen die Bücher ihre Kunden finden oder nicht finden, das ist wirklich was anderes, ja? Also äh den Leuten immer so ihr Privatleben dann irgendwie äh auszugraben und das in so einen politischen Kontext zu stellen, halte ich einfach für falsch.
Das ist das ist einfach ein Umgang im im im politischen Bereich, der äh gehört sich.
Bei Julia Schramm äh will ich das ja auch sagen, weil das war ja äh auf gar keinen Fall ein politisches Buch. Das war,
ein Buch über von Julia Schramm, über Julia Schramm äh und für Menschen, die sich für Julia Schramm interessieren. Ähm da kann man das ja durchaus so sehen. Was Marina weiß wann für ein Buch schreibt, weiß ich nicht genau, muss man mal schauen.
Wollte ich, dass es
Wunsch gibt und dass ich denke, dass es ein äh ein durchaus anzubringender Punkt ist, der da gemacht wurde. Du siehst das nicht so, weil die Personen dürfen machen, was sie wollen.
Nee, ich sehe nur, dass es einem das von der eigentlichen Diskussion abbringt, wie das jetzt hier auch grade der Fall ist, ja, anstatt dass wir uns darüber unterhalten, was sind die tatsächlichen Vorschläge, was sind die Änderungswünsche, was sind die Begründungen dafür? Reden wir halt über Quatsch. Das finde ich einfach, ich prangere das an.
Du hast mit Julia Schramm angefangen.
Nee, nee, du hast gesagt, zwei Damen, so kannst du mir nicht kommen.
Also, die wichtigsten Eckpunkte
Die Piratenpartei die Rechte der Urheber stärken, also sie sollen hauptsächlich stärker gegenüber dem Verlag sein, das heißt der der Urheber äh soll mehr äh Kraft gegenüber seinem Verlag haben. Das
das heißt, sie wollen äh diese Möglichkeiten dieser beschränken und sie wollen vor allem äh die Übertragung des Nutzungsrechts auf maximal zwanzig Jahre beschränken. Das heißt, nach zwanzig Jahren äh profitiert
kann der Verlag dann nicht mehr irgendwie so ein Killefit machen, sondern du bist wirklich, hast deine Nutzungsrechte wieder selber. Ähm,
Sie wollen Bildungseinrichtungen von Urbeirichtsabgaben befreien? Also da geht's hauptsächlich dann um äh wissenschaftliche Publikationen,
Schul- und Unterrichtsberau äh Gebrauch äh Schulfunksendung und sowas, also die,
dem Bildungsbereich irgendwie so so weit wie möglich vom Urheberrecht befreien. Amtliche Werke sollen Urheberrechtsfrei veröffentlicht werden. Äh die Dauer des Urheberrechts soll gesenkt werden,
ähm das ist sehr geil, da haben sie, sagen sie, äh äh zehn Jahre nach dem äh Tod wäre ja wohl mehr als ausreichend. Das wird ja wirklich also dieses,
ähm aus diesen zehn Jahren greift dann die äh das greifen sich ja dann die Urheberrechtsbefürworter raus und sagen
Ja äh die wollen das Urheberrecht auf zehn Jahre verkürzen. Nein, sie wollen das Urrecht verkürzen auf Lebensdauerplus zehn Jahre. Was ich immer noch völlig utopisch lang finde, ja.
Ja, aber was auf jeden Fall schon mal ein interessantes Kompromissangebot ist, gerade im Hinblick auf die aktuell existierende.
Richtig, aber aber da darf ich vor allem auf deinen äh Podcast zum Urheberrecht beim Chaos-Radio Express verweisen, der vermutlich mit,
Wenn ich mich recht entsinne, Matthias Spielkampf war, äh in dem er nämlich genau erklärt hat, warum eine Verlängerung des Urheberrechtes immer so einfach möglich ist, werden eine Kürzung
enorm schwierig ist, weil du dann quasi bestehende rechte Leuten wieder wegnehmen willst,
Das heißt, eigentlich müsstest du, wenn du es mit rechten Dingen machen möchtest, wenn du die Urheberrechtsfrist für siebzig Jahre nach dem Tod auf zehn Jahre nach dem Tod verlängern willst, dann brauchst du sechzig Jahre dafür.
Weil du es äh in neunundsechzig, achtundsechziger Schritten rund.
Ja gut, aber man kann das ja mal fordern. Also das finde ich ja völlig äh äh legitim, dass man das.
Das ist eine legitische Forderung, wunderbar.
Das ist eine legitim, ja klar.
Ja. Das darf auch Marina Weißpflanzlich. Ich darf auch fordern, dass ich heiße.
So, private Tauschbörse sollen erlaubt werden, privater Verkauf soll ermöglicht werden, ist ja auch ein ein eine Schwierigkeit, da gab's vor ein paar Wochen so einen schönen
Schönes Gerücht, das sich aber dann als nicht wahr herausstellte, da wurde behauptet, Bruce Willis wolle Apple verklagen, weil er laut AGB äh seine iPhone Apps nicht an seine Kinder vererben kann,
und gesagt hat, das habe ich bezahlt und wenn ich sterbe und mein iPhone geht über an meine Kinder, dann äh sollen die äh sollen die auch die Apps erben. Interessanter.
Punkt, ja.
Interessanter Punkt, ja. Äh nicht gewerbliche Mashups und Remixes erlauben, ja, also die ähm,
äh ja, eine Remix-Kultur ermöglichen, Fair-Use. Ähm das sind so die die wichtigen, die wichtigen Punkte, die äh in diesem hundertseitigen Dokument zweiundneunzigseitigen Dokumente angesprochen werden. Klingt,
alles sehr gut und man muss dazu mal sagen, dass also wenn sich jetzt
Also es wird natürlich nicht aufhören, die Angriffe auf die Piratenpartei aufgrund ihrer und vor allem auf äh andere dem Urheberrecht kritische äh Gruppierungen werden natürlich nicht äh enden,
ähm aber wenn man sich das so durchliest, ist das alles andere als ein,
radikaler Vorwurf. Das könnte man als ein ein radikaler Vorschlag. Es ist ein moderater sehr sinnvoller,
Vorschlag zu einer behutsamen Anpassung des Urberichts an die äh neue Zeit.
So. Ich will nicht sagen, er hat große Chancen angenommen zu werden, aber ich meine, er macht ja auch äh äh durchaus Sinn, ähm mit mit zumindest halbwegs
realistischen oder aus einer progressiven Sicht heraus schon mit Kompromissen angereicherten ähm Ansatz da äh ranzugehen. Finde ich gut.
Anmerkungen zum Thema Urheberrecht.
Nö, ich habe, konnte die Papiere noch nicht lesen, was ich mich grade frage, ist welchen Stellenwert innerhalb der Gesamtpartei hat dieses Papier aus NRW jetzt, weil da gibt's ja auch noch dieses andere Papier aus von einem Mitglied der Berliner Fraktion und.
Ne?
Die unterscheiden sich und wo ist das Statement der Gesamtpartei.
Das wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich erst finden, ne? Sind nicht demnächst wieder, ist nicht demnächst wieder Bundesparteitag mit Programminhalten oder äh ich habe gerade den den Zeitplan da nicht äh ganz parat.
Es gibt, wie, was wohl vermutlich dann eher Bundespartei ist, ist dann dieses Urheberrechtsdialog, äh diese Urheberrechtsdialogs Broschüre,
Ähm da geht's aber nicht um konkrete Gesetzes äh Vorschläge. Deswegen fand ich jetzt den äh aus NRW einfach mal inhaltlich so spannend, weil er tatsächlich einfach mal auch wie ein Gesetzesvorschlag ähm formuliert und ähm,
kommentiert ist und dieses was was wir diese Broschüre, die da jetzt als Urheberrechtsdialog kommt, das ist eher so was im Einzelnen äh fordern wir,
äh vom Formulierung, äh die also immer noch nicht so wirklich in in Gesetzescode da irgendwie stehen,
Deswegen fand ich dieses NRW-Gerät äh erstmal am spannendsten.
Ähm was die Bundesposition zu diesem Urheberrecht ist, da werden sich sicherlich noch da wird noch viel Popcorn äh die die äh die,
Das Internet fluten, ja, bis bis man sich da einig ist, ja.
Na gut, aber ich meine, ich find's ja schon mal gut, dass das überhaupt mal ein bisschen konkreter wird und einfach ähm sich in einem Bereich befindet, die jenseits des normalen Geschreis mit es müsste alles anders werden, sich bewegt.
Ja, hm, aber ich prognostiziere mal, dass das äh die Medien erstmal überhaupt nicht interessieren wird, äh weil
solange da gemäßigte, progressive äh einhundert äh Seitendokumente von von der Piratenpartei formuliert werden, äh gibt's da äh keine großen ähm.
Machen wir uns nix vor. Das wird alles noch sehr lange dauern und alles extrem blutig werden. Und bis vor allem die Medien da anfangen, ja einen kooperativen Stil an den Tag zu legen, ja, beim Bereich, wo sie selber so äh sehr davon betroffen sind. Das ist halt schwierig, ganz abgesehen von der
europäischen und globalen Dimensionen die urheberrecht hat nicht wahr?
Die Fronten liegen da sowieso ganz anders und wenn man jetzt irgendwie erstmal anfangen mit Nordrhein-Westfalen, dann ist zumindest mal ein Anfang gemacht. Wichtig hier ist, Röberrecht,
beginnt langsam,
sich einen eigenen Raum in politischen Diskurs zu erarbeiten. Das ist was Neues, ja? Das gab es so bisher nicht, das ist etwas, was kaum,
bis nicht hinterfragt wurde von der Politik, also überhaupt nicht in Frage gestellt wurde in irgendeiner Form und jetzt ist es zumindest auf der Agenda.
Habe ich eine andere Vorstellung von politischem Diskurs, weil was jetzt eigentlich zum Urheberrecht stattfindet, ist ja äh im im medialen Bereich sind es kein politischer Diskurs mehr, dass er nur noch äh Theater.
Ja, aber es wird diskutiert, das ist das, was ich meine. Also, äh, es ist dasselbe Theater hatten wir auch mit Netzpolitik im Allgemeinen
und auch das ist mittlerweile ein stehender Begriff äh geworden und äh auch da ist noch ein langer Weg zu gehen. Man kann da nicht die Lösung von heute auf morgen erwarten.
Kommen wir zu den anderen äh Streitpunkten der Woche. Äh alles muss sauber werden, ne?
Und äh deswegen wurde ausgerufen, die IT ähm von der EU Kommission oder äh wer hat den den Begriff in den Ring geschmissen?
Da bin ich ein bisschen mit Schuld an der EU Kommission, aber eigentlich ähm geht das zurück auf einen niederländischen Kollegen, den niederländischen nationalen Koordinator für Terrorismusbekämpfung und Sicherheit unter der Linus besser Niederländisch kann als ich, darfst du den Namen sagen?
Hat sich gedacht es gibt zu viel Terrorismus im Internet.
Ja. Ist schlimm.
Und hat dann mal mit dem Innenministerium aus Deutschland und Großbritannien äh sowie ähnlichen Stellen in Belgien und Spanien gedacht, dagegen müssen wir was tun,
Europol zusammengesetzt,
und das Clean IT-Projekt gestartet hat bei der EU Kommission Geld beantragt, vierhunderttausend Euro, hat er auch bekommen und die machen jetzt seit einem Jahr diverse Konferenzen, auf denen sie ja,
sich überlegen, wie man dem Terrorismus im Internet Herr werden kann. Die setzen sich zusammen mit Antiterrorbekämpfern, Polizeien,
aber auch Internetindustrie quasi ISPs und die äh Providern, aber auch anderen Anbietern,
so ein bisschen wird erzählt, dass die zu tun haben, wirklich Leute der Internetindustrie da hinzubekommen. Wir sind alle nicht so happy, da mit dabei zu sein,
jedenfalls habe ich da im Februar schon mal kurz drüber berichtet, dass in diesen Treffen,
nur komische Sachen rauskommen, komische Verständnisse von Internet, überhaupt von ihrer Aufgabe, die sie überhaupt leisten wollen.
Seitdem gab es weitere Treffen, unter anderem in Berlin und vor anderthalb Wochen auch wieder in Amsterdam und da gab's dann schon äh,
zusammengeschriebene Zusammenfassung von den vorherigen Treffen, was man denn so mal alles fordern könnte, um den Terrorismus im Internet Herr zu werden. Und da ist in der Liste rausgekommen, so ein, weiß ich nicht, fünfzehn oder wie viele Seiten PDF.
Zweiundzwanzig.
Dreiundzwanzig.
Wo irgendwie einmal das worst of Internetpolicy zusammengefasst ist, die fordern ja quasi alles. Ähm wichtige Anmerkungen ist noch,
Angeblich haben das die Anwesenden auf diesen Treffen gesagt, äh das könnten Industrie, aber auch Terrorbekämpfer äh sein und das gibt einen wahnsinnig freien Austausch der Konferenz. Alles, was jemand sagt, wird der aufgenommen. Das heißt doch nicht, dass das alles durchgesetzt wird,
aber es äh da stehen viele gefährliche Vorschläge drin,
und es wird jetzt noch eine Konferenz in Wien geben im November und im Februar soll das in Brüssel vorgestellt werden, was dieses Projekt empfiehlt, wie man dem Terrorismus im Internet her wird.
Also erstmal ich glaube in dem Dokument jetzt diese schöne Trennung, das steht vorne auf dem Deckblatt. Ähm das, was äh immer drüber steht,
Ist eigentlich so die Liste von den Dingen, für die es ähm großen Konsens.
Aber nicht,
abschließenden Konsens gab, also sie müssten nochmal neu formuliert werden oder es gab einigen Widerspruch. Das ist so, das steht immer unter. Da muss man so ein bisschen äh,
vorsichtig sein und sie haben jetzt diesen diese Implementierungsphase ist ja echt schon mal ganz schön, das ist so der der Zwei-Jahres-Plan. Da steht zwar noch Tubi Diskas drüber, aber wenn über einen Zweijahresplan steht, dann heißt das wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich. Äh es geht die,
die tatsächliche Zeitplanung an und weniger die Ziele die verfolgt werden wollen oder?
Man muss das Projekt jetzt einordnen. Das ist eins von vielen äh freien Projekten, die nicht unmittelbar äh aus der Politik
wollen nicht aus der EU-Politik direkt, sondern eben aus Strafverfolgungsbehörden, einzelnen Ländern, äh die jetzt quasi einmal im Katalog erstellen, was sie denn alles haben wollen,
Wenn sie denn könnten,
Sie fordern jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Onlinepatrouille, eine Abschaffung von, also 'nen klaren Namenszwang, Aufhebung von Anonymität, dass ähm Provider, also das Firmen,
ihre Firmennetze sperren und filtern können sollen, Gesetze, die das verbieten, sollen abgeschafft werden
Hosting Provider sollen allen upgelogen äh
hochgeladenen Content scannen nach was auch immer Terrorismus und wie gesagt, das Problem ist auch noch nicht so ganz äh definiert. Verlinken auf terroristische Inhalte, soll strafbaren ähm,
Also einmal, was sich was sich mit Agencys und Terror bekämpfe, wünschen,
wie man im Terrorismus im Internet kann und was man machen kann, was,
direkt Provider und Internetfirmen machen können, ohne dass diese den Umweg über ein Gesetz, was das vorschreibt, gehen müssen. Das ist so ganz klarer Auftrag des Projekts.
Genau, unter anderem war ja dieser schöne, dieses schöne Ding drin, ähm bei der auf, bei der öffentlichen Auftragsvergabe,
man äh darauf sollte quasi die äh das Verhalten der,
Anbieter gegenüber den Law Inforcement Agencys
als Vergabekriterium berücksichtigt werden. Das heißt, wenn du öffentliche Aufträge haben willst, dann äh verhälst du dich äh hoffentlich mal unseren Behörden gegenüber
vernünftig, weil wenn wir irgendwie merken, dass unsere Anfragen bei dir zu lange dauern oder du uns zu hohe Preise dafür in Rechnung stellst, machen Provider übrigens, für die darüber finanzieren die sich ihre äh Strukturen, wenn da Anfragen kommen, schreiben die auch eine Rechnung,
Ähm da, dass sie also sagen, okay, ähm das ist das ist jetzt ein Kriterium bei der Vergabe öffentlicher Aufträge.
Man sieht völlig freiwillig.
Das ist echt eine ist echt eine spannende Geschichte. Eine andere Sache, die mir die mir da aufgefallen ist, ist, dass sie viel von den Enduser-Control-Filters reden. Also, von,
Terrorismus filtern, die ich quasi auf meinem Computer installiere, damit ich damit das Internet mir nicht mit Terrorismus,
Ich glaube, was sie meinen, sind oder was sie eigentlich im Sinn haben, sind natürlich äh,
andere Filter, also irgendwas, ich könnte mir nur vorstellen, dass es irgendwie Kinderschutzprogramme sein sollen oder was oder eben und das wird auch hier im im Fließtext dann äh sehr offensichtlich Filter,
die zum Beispiel Firmen in ihren Netzen anwenden, um äh ihre Nutzer da in äh einzuschränken. Ähm,
relativ relativ spannend, was was da so alles äh dabei ist. Also wollen sie irgendwelche Marktstandards und die Filterhersteller sollen oder Provider sollen dann dafür haftbar sein,
wenn ihre Filter nicht vernünftig anschlagen. Und das ist natürlich immer das ist wirklich die, die beste Idee, ne? Wenn du die Provider einfach dafür haftbar machst, dann werden die sofort von äh Blacklisting aufsteigen,
dann hast du so 'n, so 'n AOL Internet oder so wie Yahoo, anfangs angefangen hat mit diesen Inhaltsdirectories oder?
Das ganze Problem ist ein bisschen undefiniert, was ist denn überhaupt terroristischer Content im Internet? Ähm,
Das haben wir die dann denen auch immer gesagt, mit unseren Partnern Edry in Europa, was ist denn überhaupt dieser Terrorismus, den ihr bekämpfen wollt? Deswegen steht den jetzt in den neuen,
Dokumenten irgendeine EU Definition von Terrorismus drin, was aber überhaupt noch nichts darüber aussagt, wie sich denn terroristischer Content im Internet äußert. Im Februar als ich dadrüber geschrieben habe, da hatten sie dann irgendwie.
Ich glaube, da können einfach auf so einer Konferenz alle Leute, die da sind, was dazu sagen. Und dann kam dann so eine Listen zusammen, wie Terrorismus könnte sein, Tier rechte linksextreme rassistische, religiöse, rechtsextreme Separatistische und alle anderen terroristische und extremistischen Organisationen und Einzelpersonen.
Stand dran, deren Dokumenten.
Wenn sie denn extremistische Organisationen oder Einzelpersonen sind, wie auch immer, keine Ahnung, wie sich diese terroristische Content im Internet manifestiert,
ähm aber man will halt was dagegen tun,
Ich weiß, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was die konkret meinen, denn sind wir mal ehrlich, diese äh Dschihadistenforen und so, die es irgendwo gibt im Internet.
Dann macht die EU jetzt einen Riegel vor.
Die sind doch zwei Drittel der Leserinnen sind doch sowieso Dienste, oder? Manche von denen sind vom CIA gewohnt und die betreiben das nur noch weiter, damit sie gucken, von welchen IP-Adressen die Leuten da posten. Also.
Gibt's da Erkenntnisse in dieser Hinsicht oder ist das jetzt eine Vermutung von dir?
Na, es es gab mehrere Stories, wo eben das rauskam, dass das hier eher sone Dinge nicht abgeschalten hat, sondern die haben das Ding einfach geoant und dann äh geguckt. Könnte ich nochmal eine URL raussuchen.
Hat doch auch äh flatterte letztens die Meldung rum, dass äh mehrere Naziforen in Deutschland auch von äh staatlichen Stellen unterhalten werden.
Ich wäre jetzt nicht überrascht, aber ich bin jetzt über die äh konkrete äh mediale Erkenntnislage da nicht im Bilde.
Also man definiert diesen Terrorismus nicht wirklich. Man definiert auch nicht, wie der Terrorismus jetzt äh genau im Internet ähm,
Gestalt annimmt und vor allem, was man in dieser Diskussion absolut vernachlässigt, ist diese Diskussion, die wir in Deutschland hatten, um Zensursula,
Das ist in Deutschland echt ein großer Bonus. Wir haben jetzt einmal ausdiskutiert, wenn's strafbaren Content im Internet gibt,
Kann man nicht irgendwie so tun als gäbe es den nicht, sondern da muss man hingehen
die Kiste beschlagnahmen Forensik machen wo das herkommen und die Leute das Zeug aus dem Netz nehmen und die Leute verfolgen, die das dahin getan haben.
Diskussion im Bonus, den wir seit zwotausendneun, zwotausendzehn in Deutschland ausdiskutiert haben, der aber anscheinend leider noch nicht überall angekommen ist.
Nee, zumindest nicht außerhalb Deutschlands.
Ja, uns geht's sowieso recht gut. Deutschland ist auch das einzige EU-Land, was die Vorzeitensprecherungsrichtlinien nicht implementiert hat. Alle anderen haben das. Insofern, wir sind da so ein bisschen Exotenbonus, aber genau mit diesem Background müssen wir eben in diese Debatten gehen
und sagen dass dass das mal nicht geht.
Ein bisschen diffus, denn es gibt jetzt dieses Projekt, wo jetzt irgendwie das Internet draufschlägt, was auch gut ist, weil die scheiße sind,
Aber das ist nur ein Symptom von dem grundsätzlichen Problem. Es gibt ähm Milliarden an Forschungsgeldern
für so 'ne Projekte und das kommt jetzt hier von das hat DJ Home mal eben so nebenbei finanziert, also das Direktorat General so 'ne Art Ministerium der EU von nebenbei gibt's aber auch noch die CEO Internet,
von die dasselbe nochmal für angeblich Kinderständische, Kinderpornographische äh
ja Dokumentation von Missbrauch äh und so weiter machen, wo sie genau dieselben Fragen erörtern, dann gibt's diese Konsultation,
Take down not is and Take down, auch von der Kommission. Äh diesmal aber wieder von DG irgendwas mit Wirtschaft. Und da weiß die eine Hand nicht, was die andere macht
die machen teilweise die Arbeit äh parallel oder widersprechen sich sogar, so einen irgendeinen umfassenden Ansatz hat man da nicht.
Und das wirft uns als äh Gegner natürlich vor größere Schwierigkeiten. Diese clean IT-Sache ist ja deshalb hochgekocht, weil Etri dieses Paper gelegt haben,
European Digital Rights, haben das irgendwie in die Finger bekommen und geliebt,
Hätten sie das nicht getan, wer Clean IT noch ein bisschen weiter äh unter dem Radar geblieben?
Erstmal vor sich weiter wirken können. Und ich glaube, da ist ja jetzt auch die Debatte, ob wir weiter so oder ob der ob die Gegner solcher Dinge weiter so arbeiten können, dass sie,
die einzelnen Namen hochspielen, ne? Das war, glaube ich, eine.
Ja
Also wir haben im Februar ja schon mal draufgehauen, dass es auch so ein bisschen hochgekocht, aber dann untergegangen, weil niemand glaubt auch wirklich stark dran, dass dieses mit seinen hanebüchenen Vorschlägen
jetzt so durchkommt. Da sind halt ein paar Läufer mit Agencys
der ein oder andere Alibi Provider, der nicht rechtzeitig geschnallt hat, was da Phase ist und jede Menge Filterhersteller, die jetzt ein Geschäft wittern und denken sich da mal irgendwie das Worst Off aus.
Was aber ein schönes Dokument ist, weil man dann echt einmal so die die Liste hat so von von allen scheiß Ideen.
Ja aber wir dürfen nicht den Indekt Fehler machen, wo das nämlich ähnlich lief. Da hat man eben ein Projekt genommen, was irgendwie einmal die komplette Bagage an schlechten Ideen zusammenfasst,
Es ist so ein schöner, greifbarer Gegner, wo man draufhauen kann, so eine Pinata, die man uns hinhängt,
das Projekt wird dann abgeschossen und man hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun und das ist gar keine offizielle EU-Politik,
aber hintenrum gibt's ähnliche Projekte, die an Teilen davon arbeiten und die viel mehr Aussicht auf Verwirklichung dieser Policys haben. Also wir sollten,
clean IT,
abschießen, weil das eine schlechte Idee ist, aber gleichzeitig sagen, das ist nicht so eine schlechte Idee, weil das einem mal das Sammelsurium von Bösen ist, sondern jeder einzelne dieser Vorschläge, die äh äh Edri da schön seziert hat und die wir auf Netzpolitik verblockt haben, ist an sich,
kritisieren. Unter anderem eben vor dem Hintergrund unserer Diskussion,
illegalen Content im Netz gibt, dann muss ja eine Quelle entfernt werden. Aber das ist ja auch so ein Problem von äh Clean ID, haben sie ja definiert. Illegale äh Nähe,
nicht wünschenswerter Inhalt ist nicht notwendigerweise illegal oder so stand.
Vielleicht sollte man mal so ein ähm so eine Art,
Ich suche gerade noch nach einem guten äh äh Wort, ne, aber du sagst, es gibt so zehn, zwanzig Sachen, die sozusagen gegen die hier generell äh verstoßen wird. Wenn man die mal alle einzeln benennt,
Und dann ähm quasi jeden jeden für sich mit so einem so einem ähm mit so einer Quantifizierung äh belegt, wie sehr man dagegen verstoßen kann,
sozusagen so von null bis hundert Prozent,
sodass dann wann auch immer eine neue äh ein neuer Vorschlag, eine neue Gruppe kommt, dass man dann äh die quasi äh gewichtet nach diesen einzelnen äh Aspekten und daraus so ein so ein so ein so ein Anti-Freiheitsindex,
bildet. Ja also ja, hier haben wir wieder ein neues äh Projekt, das liegt auf dem Anti-Freiheitsindex bei drei Komma fünf, ja. Ist nicht so schlimm, wie äh Clean IT mit sieben Komma vier, aber äh geht schon mal so in gewisse Richtungen. Da weiß man dann auch, was man sich als nächstes stürzen. Immer so.
Oben auf der nach oben offenen Meisterskala für Grund.
Ja, was erzählt dir eben nicht nur die die schlechte Policy an sich dazu, sondern eben auch die Chance, dass das umgesetzt wird und also mit nach
der letzten Woche äh hat Clean IT nicht mehr wirklich eine Chance, in irgendeiner Form
so umgesetzt zu werden, hoffentlich andere Projekte, die dann einzelne Aspekte davon nehmen und das mit Nachdruck und mal ordentlich und nicht so zusammengeflickt schustert machen, die haben dann eventuell schon eher eine Chance und da müssen wir ganz genau drauf achten.
Wir sind gerade zwei Namen gefallen und einer, ich hatte das, hatte dieses ganze Clean IT viel mehr in Verbindung gebracht mit Cecilia Mindström.
Ähm vielleicht können wir noch ganz kurz die beiden Netzdamen Cecilia, Mamström und Neli Cruise.
Du hast es aber wirklich mit dem Netz da heute. Entschuldigung.
Habe ich schon mal Netzdame gesagt? Die also ist bekannt aus Sensidia, ne?
Genau, also vielleicht ein mini Crashkurs in europäische Politik. Ich war da ja vor zwei Wochen erst die.
Der Grund ist, warum wir dich heute hier haben.
Und weil ich den Clean Arty Artikel geschrieben habe, aber in,
Der EU gibt es drei große äh Institutionen,
Den Rat, der besteht aus den Ministern der einzelnen Mitgliedsstaaten,
Parlament, das Europaparlament mit über siebenhundert Abgeordneten auch aus allen Mitgliedsstaaten und die Kommission. Die Kommission ist so eine Art die EU Regierung jetzt mal ganz,
banal äh und unpassend ausgedrückt,
und die Kommission unterteilt sich in dreißig oder ein paar mehr als dreißig sogenannte. Das sind in etwa Ministerien,
ein Ministerium,
oder ein DJ ist das DJ Home für Innenpolitik und ja in ungefähr Innenpolitik und da ist die Kommissarin Cecilia Malmström,
Ein anderes äh DG ist das DJ.
Irgendwas mit Kommunikation, das ist recht neu, irgendwas mit Kommunikation und Internet, das ist und beide haben Budgets,
die sie an Forschungsprojekte vergeben, unter anderem, die machen ein Haufen Arbeit und
einfach mal bei dem Budget Topf von DJ Home, dass quasi untersteht nach vierhunderttausend Euro angefragt und die bekommen. Das ist auch nicht wirklich so viel Geld. Die haben da irgendwie ein paar Millionen.
Was ist denn der, was ist jetzt das genaue Verhältnis zwischen Neli Cruise und Cecilia? Könnte man sagen, eine ist die Gute, eine ist die Böse, so einfach ist es nämlich nicht, oder?
Also ganz grundsätzlich ist es ist das ungefähr wie die Minister hier in Deutschland. Das eine ist die Innenministerin, das andere ist die die Kommunikationsministerin oder so,
ähm ob jetzt eine die gute und eine die böse ist, würde ich mir nicht so,
Anmaßen zu beurteilen, denn beide haben schon Scheiße gebaut und müssen dafür kritisiert werden. Beide haben aber auch ein großes Themenspektrum, was sich jetzt nicht abschließend bewerten kann.
Ist mit innen äh unter anderem für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zuständig,
Sagt immer so blumige Worte wie, wir müssen uns um äh Akta keine Gedanken mehr machen und sich regelt das jetzt mit der Netzneutralität, aber dann will sie doch noch eine dritte Studie machen über Netzneutralität, statt mal was äh dafür zu tun.
Also ob die jetzt ja würde jetzt nicht sagen, das ist so guter Bulle, böse Bulle.
Guter Bülle weniger, böser Bulle, weniger böser Bulle.
Und die Cecilia in meinem Strömen will, hat jetzt nichts offiziell mit äh IT zu tun. Sie ist die Kommissarin von dem Directory General,
und sie und sie verantwortet den Geldtopf aus dem,
Kohle geholt hat. Und die hat sich jetzt auch äh distanziert, ja. Das ist überhaupt nicht offiziell in meinem DG angesiedelt. Das sind auch alles nur Diskussionsvorschläge und so ein und so ein Zeug. Da hat sie auf einer äh rein theoretischen Ebene recht.
Andererseits gibt's halt auch Initiativen aus ihrem ähm Verantwortungsbereich, die ähnliche Sachen vorschlagen,
Offiziell ist das halt ihre Kohle. Sie hat ja bei der Kohlevergabe sagen können, ja, aber nur, wenn hier bestimmte Kriterien wie Ethikkommission oder Einhaltung der äh ja bestimmter Grundsätze oder
Das muss alles auf äh Gesetzen basieren und nicht irgendwie so eine freiwillige,
Partnership wie ihr jetzt vorschlagt. Sowas hätte sie theoretisch äh zu diesem Projekt sagen können. Also sie hat das nicht verhindert und da nicht eingegriffen, aber sie saß ja jetzt, glaube ich, nicht auf diesen Arbeitstreffen.
Kommen wir, kommen wir zu den kürzeren Meldungen, oder?
Ja, das wäre gut.
Der das Meldegesetz, welches ja in Rekordgeschwindigkeit durch den Bundestag ging. Ich glaube, wir hatten ja damals äh Berichte, das waren sechs Sekunden oder was waren das, oder zehn? Wenig Sekunden unter sechzig, genau, irgendwie.
Unter sechzig sechs waren's nicht, aber es ging alles innerhalb einer Minute. Das ging also sehr schnell durch den Bundes. Alle drei Sitzungen. Alles? Alle drei, na wie heißt das nicht, Sitzung?
Das ging also sehr schnell durch den Bundestag. Alles, ja, ja. Lesungen.
Zweite und dritte Lesung.
Zweite und dritte war's nur. Okay. Mhm.
Relativ flott. Bundesrat nicht ganz so. Äh da wird es jetzt ist es erstmal gescheitert an der Mehrheit von Fürbot und Piratenpartei, wie ich auch wie man auf Twitter.
Was?
Twitter liest, bekommt man den Eindruck, oder?
Das hat jetzt Linus gesagt.
Ähm also das jetzt erstmal gescheitert. Ich finde bin das nicht in Ordnung, dass ich jetzt.
Was das ausbaden muss.
Genau, also es ist äh es ist erstmal gescheitert und äh ist nun auf dem Weg in den Vermittlungsausschuss. Das war eine Hoffnung, die eigentlich alle zu diesem Gesetz geäußert hatten,
dass es mindestens nochmal in diesen Vermittlungsausschuss gehen muss und zunächst einmal im Bundesrat scheitert und wir werden sehen wie es da weitergeht.
Ich halte das Wort gescheitert für ein bisschen groß. Das geht jetzt nochmal in eine andere Abstimmungsphase. Also das die äh Debatte, das wurde nicht,
nur nicht sofort angenommen. Das geht jetzt noch mal in den Vermittlungsausschuss. Das Gremium, das zwischen Bundestag und Bundesrat vermittelt. Dort wird aber auf der Basis das,
Im Bundestag verabschieden den Gesetzentwurfs und den Änderungsvorschlägen, die da äh Bundesrat gemacht äh hat
und den Änderungsvorschlägen, die dann mittlerweile ein paar Bundestagsabgeordnete auch eingesehen haben, nachdem die vom Fußballspiel zurückgekommen sind, äh diskutiert. Das ist jetzt nicht so, als ob dieses komplette, als ob dieser komplette Gesetzentwurf nochmal neu aufgerollt wird,
jetzt geht's der öffentliche Aufreger ist ja die Frage, gibt es ein Opt-In oder ein Opt-out,
Die Weitergabe von Daten bei Meldeämtern an berechtigte Stellen auf deutsch äh die Firmen, die das von den Meldeämtern kaufen.
Muss ich äh jetzt beim Meldeamt sagen,
Nee, ich will das nicht oder wird das die Pforten nicht gemacht? Und ich muss ein Häkchen setzen, wenn ich das möchte.
Darüber wird die Diskussion geben, wobei das halt auch wieder ein großes äh,
Paket ist, was auch andere kritikwürdige Punkte hat, außer diesem öffentlichen Aufreger, die habe ich auf Netzpolitik mal kurz verblockt, aber jetzt auch nicht mehr komplett parat. Auf jeden Fall,
dreht das eine neue Schleife und mindestens an diesem wird wohl nochmal was gedreht werden.
Auf jeden Fall sind sie alle ganz glücklich, dass sie jetzt nochmal äh drüber reden dürfen und da nicht die volle Peinlichkeit dieser ganzen Geschichte ausbaden müssen,
Mal gucken, was ihnen noch alles so einfällt. Ja, ansonsten ähm gibt's äh Auswirkungen.
Facebook hat äh bekannt gegeben, dass sie die Gesichtserkennungsfunktion in Europa,
äh ausschalten möchten. Und zwar zum fünfzehnten Oktober, wollen also alle Nutzerprofile, die es bis jetzt äh dieser bis jetzt irgendwie erstellt haben, zur Gesichtserkennung löschen,
Und ähm.
Wird also wollen diese ganze Sache auf Eis legen. Das heißt also, was macht Facebook? Sie führen eine sie benutzen offensichtlich eine Gesichtserkennungssoftware, die ähm,
genauso gemacht ist, wie es sinnvoll ist. Sie schlägt den Nutzern,
vor, sag mal, ist auf diesem Bild nicht die Person zu sehen, die du kennst? Sag mal, ob ja oder nein,
und ähm dadurch, dass man's dann bestätigt, ähm,
Dadurch, dass dadurch, dass man's dann bestätigt, äh lernt diese Software und schärft quasi ihre Gesichtserkennungsalgorithmen.
Und ähm da geht's also datenschutzrechtlich natürlich einige Schwierigkeiten, weil oder einige Einwände bei Facebook damit biometrische Daten sammelt und auswertet und wahrscheinlich mit aufgrund seiner großen Nutzerbasis und des
ständigen
reinladens neuer Bilder durch die Nutzer und das verifizieren dort innerhalb kürzester Zeit wahrscheinlich den besten Gesichtserkennungsalgorithmus äh der Welt äh entwickelt,
Und ähm es gab also Kritik von allen möglichen Datenschützern und Facebook hat gesagt, okay, wir nehmen diese Kritik jetzt erst mal an. Wir gehen trotzdem davon aus, dass das Datenschutz richtig
in Ordnung ist, was wir da machen, aber wir legen die Funktion zunächst einmal auf Eis, um dann in Absprache mit den Datenschützern äh dieses Feature irgendwann wieder einzuführen.
Welche Funktion wird denn genau eingestellt.
Das ist genau der Witz nämlich, was, welche Funktion, also,
Im Prinzip löschen sie das, was sie bis jetzt an Profilen haben. Die Funktion selber können sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht einstellen.
Also wahrscheinlich können sie sagen, okay, wenn äh diese Person irgendwie in Europa ist, es ist jetzt zum Beispiel auch eine Frage, ne? Wo woran erkennen sie jetzt, ob sie's in Europa ausschalten?
Na ja, schalten sie in Europa für alle aus oder äh nur für Europäer oder äh nur wenn du sozusagen von der europäischen IP kommst, also es ist äh
Die erste Frage, die ich mich frage, zweite ist ja, Gesichtserkennung kann ja durchaus auch Datenschutz äh technisch interessante positive Auswirkungen haben. Also,
dass anderen,
diese Funktion zur Verfügung gestellt wird für mein Gesicht. Das ist ja das eine, ja, aber man könnte das ja auch so als Watchdock äh durchaus äh schätzen, wenn andere Leute einen selbst
dass man dann entsprechende Hinweise bekommt.
Dass das zum Beispiel, aber das hattest du ja im Prinzip auch vorher so mit diesen äh mit dem manuellen Tag ging einfach nur ohne Gesichtserkennung, konntest.
Dass man das mitgeteilt bekommt, ja.
So und so hatte ich in diesem Bild markiert, meistens war das dann irgendwie ein Goalsee, wo dann irgendwie so ein.
Du wirst den Goatzy markieren.
Ja gut, aber aber mit Gesichtserkennung kann das ja auch funktionieren, dass du sozusagen auf ein Bild hingewiesen wirst, ohne dass du dort getagt.
Genau, also das das hat auch Vorteile, es hat aber auch zum Beispiel äh große Vorteile für ähm Strafverfolgungsbehörden, die äh sage ich mal so, das Bild von der Überwachungskamera quasi einfach mal auf ihr Facebook-Profil hochladen,
und warten, was Facebook sagt, so,
Auf deinem Bild scheint äh so und so zu sein. Ähm stimmt das?
Bevor man es veröffentlicht hat.
Also ich habe diese Funktion selber äh nie gefühlt, weil ich Facebook nicht nutze, aber,
oder dass man vielleicht grundsätzlich im Rahmen eines Clean IT Projektes so 'ne Art AP für für Strafverfolgungsbehörden anbietet, lade mal ein Bild rein und wir sagen mal ungefähr wer wir glauben, wer das sein könnte nach.
Wir sagen euch auch, ob das sauber ist.
Wir sagen euch, ob das ein Terrorist ist.
Genau, auf diesem Foto siehst du nicht ganz sauber aus. Was war los?
Würde aber auch gern mal wissen, was konkret die jetzt abgeschaltet haben. Ich habe jetzt auch nur die Presseberichterstattung gelesen und da steht äh ja, sie bieten diese Funktion in Europa nicht mehr an. Heißt das, der Algorithmus,
scannt trotzdem jedes Bild und präsentiert das noch nicht nur nicht mehr für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer,
oder wird das von Bildern, die aus Europa hochgeladen werden, gar nicht mehr gemacht und vor allem die viel größere Frage ist, wer kann das kontrollieren? Weil im Endeffekt müssen wir ja Facebook glauben, dass sie das äh so machen, wie sie das sagen.
Also
wie gesagt, in diesem Artikel findet sich der Satz, dass sie äh bisher erstellte Profile äh löschen, das also so ein Ding muss ja auf eine Daten bestehende Datenbasis zurückgreifen. Die scheinen sie offensichtlich äh zu löschen und ähm
damit ist der Algorithmus auf jeden Fall sehr stark beschnitten, wenn sie's im Hintergrund trotzdem machen, müssten sie's müssten sie's,
Sie es machen, dass Sie sich darauf beschränken, wenn also Leute freiwillig jemanden taggen. Das heißt, Sie könnten das auch im Hintergrund weiterlaufen lassen. Ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen, dass Sie sagen,
du das,
auch eine ganze Menge CPU diese ganze Gesichtserkennerei und wenn wir jetzt auch offiziell bekannt geben, dass wir es nicht mehr machen, dann lassen wir es auch einfach mal aus. Wir haben hier noch den Rest der Welt
um unseren Algorithmus zu schärfen und was der lernt können wir auch nachher
noch bei Europa einsetzen, wenn wir diese Funktion denn dann wieder implementieren. Also würde ich
erstmal keinen großen Zweifel daran haben, dass Facebook diese Funktion vielleicht auch tatsächlich nach allen Regeln der Kunst
deaktiviert, wobei das natürlich auch nur ein paar Kommentarzeichen in ihrem PHP-Code sind. Ich glaube, äh Facebook ist ja immer noch im PHP geschrieben. Ähm,
dass es sie natürlich irgendwie ein müdes Arschrunzeln kostet, das wieder anzuschalten, wenn sie sich denn dann mit den ihren mit der irischen Datenschutzbehörde einig geworden sind, die ja für Facebook
zuständig ist. Weil Facebook-Dasein Europa Unternehmenssitz hat.
Trump, wir werden's äh vielleicht noch herausfinden. Aber jetzt wissen wir's nicht.
Wie gesagt, also ich gehe davon aus, dass sie die Funktion tatsächlich ausgeschaltet haben und wir werden äh sehen, wann sie sie wieder einschalten, weil sie, wie gesagt, sagen, wir gehen nach wie vor davon aus, dass das äh problemlos wieder machbar ist.
Das bringt uns an das Ende der Sendung. Und Herren. Andre, vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ähm und äh was nicht. Gibt's denn sonst noch äh irgendwelche Sicherheitshinweise, die wir schon immer mal geben wollten?
Sicherheitshinweise.
Ja, also ich wollte nur mal kurz mal sagen, also wir machen das jetzt seit fast einem Jahr hier, oder?
Nee, kann ja nicht sein, also neununddreißigste Folge, ich weiß nicht genau, wann die erste war, aber wenn wir's ein Jahr machen würden, hätten wir eine Zweiundfünfzigste Folge.
Ähm.
Hatte doch Urlaub.
Wir hatten auch mal Urlaub, aber es wäre also in der Richtung.
Ich schaue grad mal, ich äh weiß nicht, es war ein bisschen später, achtundzwanzigster zehnter, aber wir rollen sozusagen, also wir sind jetzt äh elf Monate schon dabei, ne?
Dann ist bald einjähriges Jubiläum.
Genau. So, nichtsdestotrotz, der äh Zuspruch zum Format war äh äh kontinuierlich und stetig äh steigend und das finden wir gut,
gut, dass das so ein Format äh da überhaupt äh in der Gunst der Hörer steht. Und deswegen ähm bleiben wir auch dabei.
Wenn wir noch zwei, drei Mal ausfallen lassen, könnten wir, glaube ich, die Einjahresfolge mit der Nummer zweiundvierzig haben. Das wäre natürlich schon eigentlich angemessen.
Ich will mal sehen, was ich machen will.
Ausfall müsst ihr nicht.
Okay, das war's. Bis bald. Auf Wiederhören. Ciao. Tschüss.
Auf Wiederhören. Ciao.
Tschau.